oh my
God oh my oh my God oo that's
scary oh my god oh we lost everything
and it's company day wait I keep
reiterating this is you pick the really
dangerous places right away before we
have like a teleporter L doy we always
knew good right after bat and then you
keep having this idea and it's it's
never worked it's never once worked see
I've never even used a jetpack I got
this emote for us cuz it's called best M
oh oh my God it's on my
head it's a hoarding bug give me that
give me that give me that what are you
doing yeah you better give me that aha
it's mine now it's mine
now I think you just di the table
did they both die to a loot bug let's
just say we did no let's say yeah loot
bug that's what got it I
heard
now kind of just got to guess where it
is
dark how did he see
that hello oh my God he's
cheating
oh my God he's
cheating he's got his brightness turned
up you know where Mark ended up I'm
going to go ahead and just uh put it out
there Mark's definitely dead right I
imagine so yeah I was going to show him
my wiener but I couldn't find him I
can't believe W would just cheat like
that hey Mark I'm sorry you died I hope
it was
funny loot bugs am I
right
what oh you're going your own why was
going to say I found more up over here I
might need a hand grabbing it oh this
door's locked okay
well oh hey this door's
locked it's definitely something good
behind
it there's a fire exit I don't wait
actually I do trust this fire I think
this where I came in it was locked oh
I'll double check if I die horribly you
know I was wrong yep n that's that's not
funny at all not that horribly where was
this loot you were speaking of come on
me whoa I miss
Mark I remember when he was oh another
key uh in that room there's at least a
TNT
yep find the power supply oh and of not
I don't trust that fire exit that was
probably real we just gra power supply
and get the hell out of here yeah that's
fine
I didn't hear him I heard a muffled
distant Mark noise go up and then we go
up here
Mark
Ren someone named
Sally I'm really kind of got away from
us there well that's just that was just
such a fun exploration you know
I got an extra
key see where Mark ended up
oh uh loot bug
probably well that's unfortunate if you
look at the monitor up there looks like
where you want to be down here looks
like where Mark is yeah I say we dance
in honor of Mark
sure best mat
dance Mark you died andk Mark you aren't
here with
usk so good to not be the one that's
dead oh I yeah I'm like I don't want to
shove it in Mark's face hey so I've made
an interesting
Discovery gravity so Bob you know how
Wade's been mocking us and our lack of
skill and us you know falling into pits
of Despair and whatnot yes I discovered
that uh this this man right here is
cheating how so you can use the you see
I discovered it because the room that I
was in when I looked upon the chasm I
could see no ledge because it was dark
completely dark and then I realized Wade
jumped right onto the platform with no
problem he has his gamma turned up like
a coward um I have a counter point if
you scan it briefly lights things up so
you can see where to
jump that is
[Music]
true I still posit that you have your
gamma turned up I still say no no
laughing no sh no
sh go ahead go ahead no sh do you or do
you not have your gamma up I
don't all right my argument is crumbled
around
me I will I will part if I open this do
I die or do Mark is go into your monitor
settings yes and turn your contrast and
sharpness and Gamma up to like a gilon
all right here's another here's another
argument if there was a setting in game
you know I would pause it you could be
correct if I have to go through and
change the settings on my monitor do I
really seem like the type no not that I
meant the game the game game is there a
way to change your brightness in the
game I don't see one yeah it is oh game
of brightness the little o is touching
the black line okay all
right anyway I seem like a
fool you can turn it up a little bit if
you no no no I would never do that such
a thing talked about distractable on our
podcast you know what you are getting
older no no I just assumed that um some
things about anyway lot
day company
bear bear bear bear bear bear bear wi
Wier wi Wier did you see our wiener I
did I heard it slapping around yeah I
was was
witnesser where' it go oh there it is
all right fall straight down when
you hey Mark hey Mark hey Mark what's up
nice oh hang on hang on no hang on hang
on wa the [__] hang on hang on hang on
hang on wait wait wait Mark wait it
worked over here hang on there
oh wow how do I do that grab it I can't
Gras it firmly I can't firmly grasp it I
can't I can't I can't I got it no I
didn't you didn't get it how did you how
did you grab it this hard to
grab it's
slippery no not
quite I don't want to play I'm going to
turn in money I want to play fling the
wiener back up oh hey just tucking that
in there wait you could have gotten
yours in there you could have gotten
yours in there wa you could have gotten
yours in
there bear bear bear bear bear floating
floating bear bear bear bear seems
fine Bear's dead going buy some walkies
and flashlight hey that would be really
good that would be really good o walkies
are 80% off oh [__] buy five flashlights
are on sale too oh [__] buy 10 uh
they're not that cheap so I bought five
but okay I'm going to get you that jetp
pack Bud I'm going to get it for you I
want it I'm going to get you that jetp
pack I'm going to make it through these
next yeah I'm going to make through
these next levels and we're going to get
you that jetpack good get for you really
good cuz I'm not going to do good I'm
going to do really good for you I
apprciate I'm going to continue to suck
a big one okay that's fair it's not it's
not a choice I'm making it's just who I
am as a
person all right that sounds good I feel
like way is spending all of our money
right now I hear a lot of Chings I hear
a lot of ch- Chings I just bought emot
it was just the emote fund oh okay let's
go to March March is free March is free
I like Fire EX and the main entrance
ways to go oh I remember March where's
all right main entrance Straight Ahead
fire exits two to the left one I'm going
fire
exit ah uh if anyone sees a toy Mari
plush that's a good
one a toy Mari like Mari
popovic uh no but yes uh also I've never
seen this before an entrance appeared to
be
blocked yeah that's what happened oh is
this going to be the weird Castle
dungeon again maybe oh it's your dang
mods yes yes it is yeah mine's blocked
[Applause]
too all right I'm
inside
I put bees on the front of the ship uh
not by the door but the other end so
whenever we take off we can go grab that
highve some extra mon does anyone still
need the gift thing or is that long gone
long gone for
me just a toy Mari plush for
[Music]
me
the I okay I done it
already Okay I don't like that I don't
like
that
did someone need a gift
box no
no
what found a weird door with two glowing
blue lights that doesn't seem to open
it's very strange uh can you repeat that
Mark what'd you find it was a door with
two glowing blue lights but it didn't
open I don't know what was
about I have no
idea I also found something called the
boink and oh an assignment
Target oh oh oh it blocks my entire
Vision I it's I have to hold it directly
in Fr my face the hell are you holding I
don't know it's a toy Mari plush uh
you're coming up to a jump I know I
there's a slime to the right too be
careful the Slime okay I see it I'm not
going that way right there there is a
slime yeah it's all good I'm not well
actually I have to go wait how do I get
back yeah you have to go past the Slime
and then go to the right to get
out it's kind of hard to see around this
plush but I'll make it yeah watch out
there's a
slime hi yeah I'm drawing it this way
see my
plush yeah no that's cool that's cool
it's pretty cool I'm going to go
goodbye it is everything explored
already I feel like I can't find any
areas I'm also struggling to find a
place it's all that way I think it's all
that way I found a way to
go all right I made it back to the ship
Freddy fast bear Freddy
Fazbear yeah Baba you got Freddy Fazbear
I didn't see any loot that way either so
so uh I don't know how good that's going
to do
you oh wait yeah you got tons of loot
there's loot uh right in front of you
and then two in the room
beyond all Bob watch out for that slime
I'm
guessing oh well uh Bob's
gone there's also another loot behind
you if you go turn around and go to the
right I I need a key I need a key to get
to it I see I
see ah well don't worry about it uh
uhoh never mind I cheated got
it I'm in big trouble I'm in big big
trouble
oh I
uh
while turrets are bad partless are
scary I don't know if you had anything
else but I figured that it was
I'm the be I
oh uhoh grab it grab it grab it grab it
grab it grab you can make it you can
make it oh my God how did you do that it
teleported me I didn't do it oh okay
well that was good oh that's nice a
there's a couple more things at the main
entrance H why does it say we collected
zero we collected so much oh yeah sorry
about the main entrance I just figured
that with two things around us of deadly
proficiency well there was two I finally
saw the dogs oh there I literally can't
stop jumping to my own death and I hate
it very much that would have been great
if that was an enemy um yeah I should
have done that actually that was a
really bad idea you should never open
presents on the ship but I should have
done that yeah I don't know what's up
with the Angry Bird but that's a thing I
mean March is clear again maybe we get
the horrible Castle yeah really isn't
that bad but like it's not great it's a
little annoying but overall good Hall I
think we're well on the way to the
jetpack get prob his jetpack you know
you know the moment I touch a jetpack
I'm going to put it on and fly off into
space kill myself and lose the jetpack
all in one Fell Swoop God I hope
so oh it's blocked
boys up back to the main
entrance is there something horrible in
there why are you dancing out
here no this isn't so bad
oh what's up wouldn't that be funny
though oh okay all right I get you
that's
[Music]
funny I'm going into this teleporter
wish me
luck I have a
key
so good luck it's too late I'm sure I
found another teleporter I'm going in
this
one
oh I'm not sure where I am but I'm alive
[Music]
still well um too wait I found another
Mark did you use the teleporter in the
in the prison cell area
or no that's different I'm going to try
this other
teleporter how far from a landmine can
you be before it activates kind of
[Music]
close uh how much what does that
mean definitely wouldn't get close
enough to touch it
hello hey Mark hey
uh I don't know where you
are okay but at the bottom waade waade
if you hear a kaboom it went
poorly okay all right hold
on oh my God man if only keys were
valuable
Jesus don't go down that way oh that's a
land
man hey man why didn't you tell me about
that one why didn't you tell me about
that one okay that's like three more
that way I you want me to point out
every single one like it would be nice
you know it' be nice it'd be nice what
are we bickering about there's landmines
that way didn't tell me
about there's one right here yeah I
[Music]
know
man so far
down I just keep going down it just
never
[Music]
stops man I think I'm lost I just keep
going deeper and I don't know where I've
come from cuz I was teleported here
here why does this have to be so
big I am Omega lost there might be a
turret in there it's a land
mine I am out of battery on my
flashlight and I am in the dark in the
deepest part possible we're watching you
on the old computer machine buddy don't
you wor B all right you going to
navigate me
out
why did you say why I thought we had
dogs I I guess we're good wait to come
to help
you that appears to be a dead end oh no
there's stairs yeah I think that's what
you
want thanks
buddy there's loot ahead of you
oh that do sound I'm dead I'm so
dead no you're fine it's moving slow
it's moving slow what is it I don't know
it's big I have a lot of valuable Loot
on me
oh when you stairs like that I can't
actually see the dot so I have no
idea goodbye everybody goodbye You're
Not Safe you're very much
not
he
dead oh yeah he's
dead how he put
back he can go I don't think I helped
Mark very much by watching him die on
the computer I've got to be honest well
at least you at least he had Comfort he
had somebody with him to comfort him I
don't think I comforted him very much
either I got to be honest at least at
least he had some guidance
I basically told him nothing of value uh
at least he wasn't
alone I mean I was there as a voice in
his ear but he was completely and
definitely alone you help you help hello
hey buddy yeah how close was I to making
it
out uh I felt pretty
close uh-huh I felt like I was right
there we're going to go to Val this is
the one with the bridges oh I like
Bridges oh I like taking fall no the
bridges are outside you should be able
to get in there no
problem I need to kill
aing the
company the
company we love the
company and I hope that I don't die you
guys see a loot let me oh hell yeah oh
you're never going to believe
it look at this
see no that's not the thing you won't
believe what wouldn't I
believe oh you'll see it and you'll
believe it but you won't believe
it
[Music]
[__]
oh boy man this place has a lot of down
spirals there is literally zero reason
to go straight from the main entrance
and goes downstairs to a big room filled
with nothing and nowhere to go the door
to the right is also a big
nothing I found the way down it's pretty
down
I'm coming down Mark okay there's
nothing
here oh okay good hey good I think you
got to jump across a Chasm you love
jumping across chasms dude if there's
one thing I can always do it's Chasm
jumps just watch this man whoop and just
do
that though it wouldn't be funny if I
messed it up though that would have been
funny hey how'd you get here I jumped
across that bridge oh
leads right to the
main oh that's nice okay
cool oh more down
okay it's one of those things oh hey
wait wait there's a bug wait there's a
bug there's a bug there's a
bug oh uh uh I didn't use the radio wait
there's a bug it's coming up towards
where you were when we were
talking never mind it's going back down
towards Mark
oh down
down come here W come
here even Downer yeah I think I got yeah
it's down there it's right there w w w w
w w Wait do the thing oh we did the
thing okay that was nice oh Freddy
Freddy Freddy Freddy Freddy Freddy
Freddy oh [__] just kind of look at him
don't really look at him right that's
the idea
yeah all
right well the other way is only blocked
by a bracket so that's
fine all yeah I'm here just I'm trying
to push him back okay good so far you
working up the stairwell is that where
you are yeah oh he's across the way
don't stare at
him which way to the way
out I'm I'm going to jump across the C
where I am where I am yeah across the
the stairs
oh oh God wait who is that who no no
no no no no no no bad no no no bad bad
how do we get out that's the way out
isn't it okay yeah that's the way out
here's what we're going to do
Bob I give you the shovel I'm going to
be bait let him attack me whenever he
grabs me hit him okay okay I'll keep an
eye on our
rears oh this help me right
there yeah just just hit him just yeah
get
get yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right all right let's get
out of here let's get out of
here
ah all right yeah
I am
very uh we alive everyone alive I'm
alive yeah okay good probably more
injured but alive I didn't know that
could happen yeah I've never done that
before anyway we're all
alive yeah feeling great it doesn't
matter if you're in if you're alive
you're living you're living living live
that's what my grandpy always said oh
yeah look oh look at all this loot look
at this loot oh loot Anvil do you think
carrying the Anvil across is what made
to collapse possibly all right kind of
heavy Who would know we have over $900
worth of stuff whoa do
we holy crap yeah we do wow well let's
turn it in we're swimming in it that's
enough for a jetpack oh God yes I want
to fly away into space so bad yeah I
mean successfully used the jetpack yeah
yeah ideally yeah
mhm I don't know what I'm doing but I
like it I like where I'm at how do we
get back to type company we love the
company
[Music]
confirm oh
yeah okay oh man the thing made me
sneeze
good I I honked my horn and then my horn
needed to honk itself
wow my horn is my nose oh
[Music]
yeah hey take one of these
uhoh windows open by the way windows
open the windows open windows open
doesn't look open I heard it open you
should just stay there and see if it
stays open or not I I heard
it oh no that's not good oh is it open
it's definitely open
now all
right that's fine oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah what's that
grumbling then what is the grumbling
there's a very strange breathing like
grumbling what is n it's fine that
wasn't there before should bring the
Bell or something
probably malware broadcaster is active
wait
what what does that mean what does that
mean did w just not buy us a jetpack and
spend all our money on some other thing
no we would have seen something descend
from the heavens right would we have
though would would we
we have 88 credits left on our account
already what did you buy wi uh come
here oh get it get it get it get it you
for it you wanted it you got it all
right go go
go
why does it do that
beeping okay okay probably yeah oh oh oh
oh okay all
right ooh all right yeah he's get oh oh
god oh B
oh almost almost so oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh B oh oh oh I'm fine I'm fine
I'm fine I'm okay he's good he's good
he's good he's good okay it's fine I'm
fine it seems a little hard to
control oh critical in um was that from
falling from the sky or yeah you did
kind of calamitously slam into the
ground I'm just going to try and hover
for a minute oh that's
hard
wow oh right if you let go of the thing
at all you just immediately
fall oh oh oh you okay my angles good
that very not good oh oh yeah oh oh
man walk it off walk it off walk it off
yeah just yeah yeah maybe oh my areas oh
wow that's a lot of
red walk it off walk it off you'll be
fine I'm fine that's good all right okay
cool how do I recharge the is it
batteries oh yeah it is that's amazing
batteries what happened battery powered
[Music]
fuel